Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Ani Ganguly.
I'm monitoring the session. The session is on
NCI/NIH opportunities in funding,
NCI Cancer Diagnosis Program initiatives, and
biospecimen resources for investigators.
We will try to give you as much information we have
and sharing with our colleagues. So I go first,
then Dr. Lokesh Agrawal will come next,
talk about his program. Then Dr.
Ana
Robles will come in to present her program.
After that, we'll have 15 minutes time when we will
discuss,
respond to your questions, and
answer as best as we can. Let's start.
So this is...
Why it is not moving now?
It should be the reverse way, right?
Ani, you need to click on your name.
I did.
Select your name.
Hmm?
Oh.
Select.
Yeah.
No, no, no. Here, select this.
Start.
And it goes this way.
Okay. I'm Ani Ganguly, and I have no financial
relationship to disclose.
The Cancer Diagnosis Program, or CDP,
strives to improve the diagnosis and assessment of cancer by
effectively moving the new scientific knowledge into clinical
practice.
CDP stimulates, coordinates, and funds research and
resources for the development of
innovative in vitro diagnostics and novel diagnostic
technologies and appropriate human specimens to better
characterize cancers and allow improved
medical decision-making and evaluate
the response of treatment.
This session will provide an overview of the initiatives that
address important research areas in cancer diagnosis to
advance biomarkers and technology tools for research
and clinical decision-making.
Now, first one, we will talk about the biomarker
and technologies. That's the section of our program.
And then I will talk about the biospecimen banks that we
have. After that, my colleagues will follow through with
their specific programs.
This is the diagnostic biomarker and technology program
that supports research to advance development of new biomarkers and
innovative technologies for cancer research and clinical decision-making.
There are four segments here. One is innovative technology
development.
That entails that the technologies and devices
for use in cancer diagnosis, prognosis, and prediction.
The next one is biomarker platform, that
integrating and applying results from biomarker research and
technology development into novel platform for cancer diagnosis.
The third one is artificial intelligence and machine
learning, developing and implementing AI
machine learning models for
analysis of data for cancer
diagnosis and prognosis. The fourth one is
liquid biopsy and non-invasive technology.
It supports technologies for analyzing ctDNA or
circulating tumor DNA, CTC or circulating tumor
cells, proteins, and other analytes for cancer
diagnosis and treatment.
Now, I will give you examples of the RFAs that are
out there so that if you're interested, you could apply for it.
This one is on exploratory developmental bioengineering
research grant, R21 mechanism.
So the purpose is to demonstrate feasibility, utility of
new capabilities or improvements in quality, speed,
efficacy, operability, cost, and/or
accessibility of solutions to problems in basic
biomedical,
preclinical, or clinical research and clinical
care delivery or accessibility.
The
RFAs are out there. The standard dates apply.
The last date is October 16, 2027.
The next one is a R01 mechanism for academic
industrial partnership for translation
of technologies for diagnosis and treatment.
Now,
here is clinical trial is not allowed.
The purpose is to deliver new capabilities for technologies and
methods relevant to the advance of cancer and
delivery of care in preclinical,
clinical, and non-clinical settings.
The NOFO specifies a partnership structure
that includes at least
one academic institution and one industrial partner.
Standard due dates apply.
The last date of submitting an application is October
5, 2027.
The third one is a U01 mechanism
on bioengineering partnership with industry,
where clinical trial is optional.
The purpose is to support research partnership
ofAcademic and industrial investigators to accelerate
development of adaptation of bioengineering tools and
technologies as robust, well-characterized solutions
that fulfill unmet needs and enhance understanding of
life science processes or
practice of medicine.
Option to participate with
NIH intramural partners. This is very
important. It doesn't happen all the time, but for this
mechanism, you can work with NIH intramural
scientists.
The last date for submission of the application is
May 2027.
Next one is I'm going to switch to
now biospecimen banks.
We have five
different banks throughout the United States, and those banks
are connected to five clinical trial
groups in this country.
So NCCN banks receive,
store, and distribute human biospecimens
collected on NCCN clinical trials.
NCCN stands for National Clinical Trials Network.
The NCCN banks provide cancer researchers with quality,
well-annotated biospecimens with associated clinical
information. This is very important.
It separates biospecimens that are available out there,
coming directly from a clinical trial,
where all the data are available with the
biospecimens. So those who are interested in developing
assays, for example, validating an assay, these
biospecimens will be very helpful.
Now these are the banks.
COG, these are short names.
COG, SWOG, ALLIANCE,
Canadian
Network banks or group, NRG, and
ECOG-ACRIN.
The Canadian bank is also, although it's not
the integral part of the five
clinical trial groups, but they also participate in it.
We also have NCORP site participation.
That means NCI's
Cooperative Oncology network. That is
more into the
prevention side of the
treatment protocol.
Next is
the specimens collected from the NCCN biospecimen
banks are from phase three, phase two, and
other trials are well annotated with clinical and
outcome data.
Specimens collected from NCORP
are NCI's Cooperative Oncology Program.
That also has
a number of biospecimens already available,
collected from cancer prevention and control clinical trials.
These are harmonized standard operating procedure
followed for preservation, processing,
and shipment of these biospecimens.
That means they are all equally
treated. Specimens initially used in NCCN
clinical trial group, investigators for integrated and
integral
biospecimen marker studies.
These specimens are not designed for
exploratory studies.
You will get the specimens if you have assays already
in an advanced stage. You want to clinically
validate your
assay. These are the specimens you are going to
use. And for the reasoning that you want to collect the
specimens from NCI or clinical trial group, you have
to write that this is what we have already done.
Now we're going to validate our assay.
Then the chances of getting is more.
The next one is continuing with the biospecimens.
Specimen remains in excess after clinical trial requirements have been
met. That's called legacy biospecimens and are available
to investigators throughout the United States for secondary
correlative studies following a defined NCCN
biospecimen access process. Now, the type of biospecimens
are available now. These are FFPE tissues,
bone marrows, peripheral blood,
serum, plasma, urine,
stool, nucleic acids, and in most cases,
digital images.
Continuing with the biospecimens.
So how do you access them? There is a navigator that is a
platform available to access these biospecimens,
and that seeks to validate prognostic, predictive, or
diagnostic power of the novel biomarkers.
Perform assay development, validation,
require large number of specimens from uniformly
treated and phenotypically homogeneous specimen
populations. Requires outcome of treatment response
data or demonstrate clinical utility.
So there is a high standard for these specimens, why you need them.
The other one is to support statistical rationale for number of
specimens and the type of data needed to demonstrate
clinical significance.
These specimens are not available or appropriate
for
exploratory studiesNow, how to
access these NCCN biospecimens? One is
through the Navigator,
and if the Navigator doesn't work for you,
you can contact the NCCN biospecimen groups
directly,
and you still have to go through the process of review and
evaluation.
There are other ways of collecting
biospecimen, that is Cooperative Human Tissue
Network, or CHTN. It has been in existence since
1987. It is a unique resource
where investigators order the
biospecimens, what they need, how they need it.
So those things are collected and distributed to you.
There are six
places where it can be done. CHTN is in
six different places. So whatever is
convenient for you, closer to you, you should contact them,
ask them to collect specimens for you for a fee,
and then they will process the specimens the way you want it.
This is not a bank, it's a procurement service.
It collects and sends the biospecimens to you.
The success of this program is very high.
We have 618 unique researchers served in the
recent past from 2022 to 2024.
Sixty-seven academic investigators
have collected specimens from there.
Over 117 specimens distributed
in different forms like fresh, frozen, and fixed tissues,
122 publications from 2022 to
2023, and the RFE is already out there,
and it
was
out there on
April 1st, 2024, so it is still running.
The next one is, and probably the last, is the Specimen
Resource Locator. It's another source that NCI
offers to locate specimens that are not
in these
banks or networks.
So it has a resource where you can go in and find
biospecimens that you need from other sources,
and this is operated by NCI.
So folks, thank you so much. And if you
want to contact people for the technology
section of this program or presentation, please
talk to Dr. Brian Sorger, and his email is here,
brian.sorger@nih.gov. And for
pathology or the biospecimen part of it, you talk
to Dr.
Hala Makhlouf,
and her email is
hala.makhlouf@nih.gov, and my
email address is my first name,
aniruddha.ganguly@nih.gov. Thank you very much.
My next speaker,
I invite Dr. Lokesh Agrawal.
Okay. All right. Okay. All right, thank you, Ani.
And if you guys haven't noticed, we have some flyers out sitting on the
chairs, so please
feel free to grab them when you leave, so that you
know most of these funding opportunities that we are going to probably talk
about, they're all in that flyer, and with the contact
information.
I'm going to mostly speak today about
what exists in the biospecimen science,
in terms of funding opportunities, and what resources that kind of
exist that we have created last few years on the biobanking
part. Especially folks
who are working on the drug resistance space, the biomarker space.
What kind of collection do we have that you can utilize for your research?
So,
no financial relationships to disclose, and this is
a snapshot for our branch. So I'm the acting chief for the
biorepositories and the biospecimen research branch.
So what do we do?
Three major areas, biobanking
which you see in the yellow. We do the funding
in biospecimen science,
data harmonization,
biospecimen and biobanking standards, which is part of the
NCI best practice which probably some of you probably would have
heard about. We have a biospecimen
research database that kind of consists
of curated literature on biospecimen
science and SOPs,
biospecimen evidence-based practices that especially if
you're working on a
specific protocol, at least in terms of if you're trying to standardize,
then it will give you guidelines. So let's say if you're working on
CTCs, ctDNA, or
if you're working on FFP tissues, there's some guidelines
on that. Similarly, on the public education part
we do have brochures, patient corner
newsletters that we kind of publish once in a while just to
guide
the patients. And in the biobanking part,
we did run
some of those projects like GTEx, BPV for which
specimens and data are still available,
which was more like a genotype expression studies,
biobanking studies, and then the Cancer Moonshot Biobank, which probably I'm going
to touch a little bit at the end.
But for the funding part of the U01, this is
thebiospecimen science
opportunity, especially when you're working and trying to validate
a biomarker, where exactly the gap
is where what we found,
speaking to a lot of investigators, that
they didn't have any funding to do any
pre-analytics.
So whenever you jump into developing a biomarker assay,
how you even collect your samples, how you process them, how you store them,
and that's where this funding opportunity kind of fills the gap.
Where what you see
right at the bottom,
which kind of encompass most right
from after you have a clinical biomarker that you have
identified or you think it's a promising biomarker, you can
take it directly and standardize using pre-analytics
and then validate it
with either one of the companion
UH2, UH3 mechanism, which
my colleague Anna is going to speak about,
and other biospecimen funding opportunity that kind of exists,
which are more technology focused, which
focuses most on
development of,
let's say, reagents. Just like you're all probably familiar with
RNA later that came out. It came out from one of these IMAD
science technologies. But I think in the context of this
talk, I think I'd probably focus mostly on the
PAR-25-325, which is
integrating this biospecimen science into clinical assay
development.
And the kind of questions for
biomarker assays, especially either liquid or tissue
biopsies that you are probably asking in this FOA
or NOFO, is what pre-analytical conditions can this biomarker
tolerate? Will the assay work on the material?
And
stability is the key because obviously, when samples are being
collected, either prospectively or they're being stored as
a part of the clinical trial, you really want to
make sure that when you analyze them,
that the protein or whatever assay that you are
working on
is kind of stable throughout. So
it kind of conducts all these dedicated studies in
biospecimen science to increase this reproducibility in clinical
research. That's the whole point.
Five-year projects,
multidisciplinary teams,
pathologists, radiologists, oncologists, I think, and we
really encourage here if you can participate in any
clinical trial or at least have somebody in your team which
has a clinical trial expertise, it's always encouraged.
And then we do have a steering committee
that is very active
with the FDA and NIST so that if you want
to take this assay further down the road
for an FDA approval, then they can actually guide you.
And in fact, NIST is very helpful in terms of developing some of these standards
and best practices as well.
And just to make a note here that this is
open to everyone, academia, industry, it doesn't matter.
We have had some successful
applications from industry as well.
This is what the grants portfolio looks like.
Total close to 24 funded grants in this
U01 mechanism. On the left are all the different cancer types,
and that these U01 grants
have. And on the right is the
types of specimens that
are being used and being
standardized. So you see it's a mix for both
solid and liquid biopsies. So we have all
kinds of biofluids are also being used in this.
And
this is the steering committee.
As I said,
what we do is meet annually and then kind of develop some
kind of best practices and foster
opportunities between all the investigators.
And
ultimately, probably we're planning to do is kind of doing a
cross-validation. And
we have also included some of these
patient advocates, principal investigators, FDA,
and NIST, as I said, on this. We do have
a seminar coming up for this,
which is going to be
on April 30th.
So
I think this probably information would be available, but I guess you can always
contact us
if you want to learn a little bit more about the next application due dates are
coming up in June and September. And this is going to be there
for another year or so, and then probably we'll work on its renewal.
The other piece that I touched a little bit before was about the
resources that what we have on
biospecimen science as a part of the research database
is the literature repository, which has close
to 3,600 curated articles.
SOP libraries is
highly, highly utilized throughout
the globe with almost close to
1.7 million downloads to date. Then we have the BEBP
series that I talked about, which are more procedural
guidelines and which have really a SOP-like level of
detail, and then you can look it up
what we have published to date and what could be useful for
youAnd we had the
fourth edition of NCI Best Practices, which is just
recently released,
which
kind of gives you the guidelines and standards for
collection of human biospecimens when you're doing clinical research.
And lastly, I would like to touch a little bit on the Moonshot
Biobank, which is
an active project going on currently as a part of NCI
10323 protocol.
It was
initiated somewhere in 2017,
with a goal to increase participant engagement,
diversity in research participant, especially
enrolling more of the
minorities like Hispanics and African Americans, engages
participants with the mostly advanced cancer in the metastatic stage with standard
care of therapy.
And the whole idea is to basically collect more
longitudinal sample sets
to understand drug resistance in
a few cancer types that we selected for our study.
So this is
a project that has been going on. It's almost
in its final stages, final year.
On the left, what you see is the different
components, the moving parts, which had the
patient registration system through the metadata RAVE and
a whole clinical data management system as well, where
I think TeraLex kind of built in with
NCCN and NCORP sites, including a dedicated
biorepository at Van Andel
Institute.
There was a component of electronic consent,
which was introduced for the very first time at NCI,
and also samples were collected
to serve the NCI Patient-Derived Model
Repository as well.
So big, complicated project, but I guess I think we did
good, at least in terms of collecting different cancer types.
What you see here is
all the different cancer types that were enrolled, including
both heme and solid cancers. And the
numbers on the right kind of
gives you an idea that how many patients we have
biospecimens for.
The good
news here, at least, we were able to meet
our goals in terms of race and partly in
ethnicity, which we see here as for Black and African
Americans,
we are able to collect around 18%, which
is
far better than what is normally is a
standard in US, which is around 12%.
In terms of Hispanics, I think we
fell a little below the bar, which around 8%.
That has to do with a lot of the sites that what we
had didn't have enough of the Hispanic
populations.
And kind of give you a brief snapshot of kind of
specimens that are there for total
1,300 or 1,350
patients. Around
1,020 subjects have longitudinal blood or tissues,
and around 300, probably one third, probably has
blood with more than two time points and tissue with two time points only,
150, which is always pretty hard to collect.
And in terms of data,
pretty comprehensive data being collected.
So clinical data
is all captured through RAVE. And then we do
have
treatment data, both targeted and non-targeted, and the response
data. And all these
genomic data that was collected on the patients at the baseline,
which is done through an Oncomine-based targeted
assay panel, is also available through CTDC.
And a lot of imaging data that has been also been done
for all of these patients, including CT scan, X-rays, and other
as the standard care of therapy is also available for these
patients.
And I think
that's about the Moonshot. I think that right now for the
Moonshot, what we are doing is
following these patients throughout another year before we
close the study so that we can collect
more of the progression samples.
And last but not the least, I want to just mention another program.
I think probably Ani covered a little bit, but I think it's an IMED
program that's been run in terms of
for the technology development projects.
It also has a biospecimen technology arm that I talked about in
one of the initial slides. But I guess if you're
interested, you can always reach out to Kelly
Crotty for more questions. I think she's at this meeting as well.
I think that's probably the last slide, and I think we'll hold on to
questions, I assume, right?
No, we don't have.
Okay.
Our next speaker is Dr. Ana I. Robles.
Thank you, Ani. Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Ana
Robles.Here
we go.
I am the Chief of the Diagnostics Evaluation Branch in
the Cancer Diagnosis Program in the Division of Cancer
Treatment and Diagnosis of the NCI, and in
the next few minutes, I will provide some
background on a funding opportunity
that provides support for biomarker assay
validation
so that the biomarkers become prepared, analytically and
clinically validated to be used in clinical studies in
cancer, and that can include clinical trials.
I have no disclosures.
And just to go right into it, the funding
opportunities that I will discuss are meant to facilitate
developing biomarkers and validating in vitro
diagnostics that will eventually improve clinical
outcomes for cancer patients.
Specifically, the funding opportunities support
both analytical and clinical validation in a sequential
manner of these molecular diagnostic assays,
which can be for cancer detection, diagnosis,
prognosis, monitoring, or prediction of
response or resistance to treatment, as well as markers for cancer
prevention.
The funding is also applicable for validation of
pharmacodynamic markers, as well as markers of
toxicity.
The funding may be used to validate assays that are
already existing and have been used in
other clinical trials or observational or population
studies, or for harmonization efforts among
different clinical sites.
The assays can also be multiplex assays.
These are assays that measure multiple biomarkers, including immune
markers,
that can be developed and validated simultaneously.
These are the two funding opportunities that I'll be focusing on,
and as you can see, they're essentially parallel.
The first one, 74, is for
assay validation,
where the award is a phased award. It's
called a UH2/UH3 phased award, and we'll go a little bit deeper
into what that means,
and provides an initial phase of analytical validation
followed by clinical validation.
And the second one is for the clinical validation
part for an assay that has already been analytically
validated.
The next application due dates are on July 10th
and October 14th of 2026, and
this funding opportunity will expire on October 15th of
this year.
So to follow up on these two opportunities,
there has been another opportunity forecasted
that is essentially
the same content, but it now contains
within this one opportunity a new issuance that
will support both the phased awards and the UH3
standalone applications for clinical validation.
As mentioned, this opportunity was already
forecasted,
but it's
not yet
determined when the application will be published, hopefully early
2027, and you will need to check
grants.gov for updated information.
The QR code can take you to the forecasted opportunity.
Before we
go into the announcement themselves, just a couple of
definitions of how these words are used within
the context of the funding opportunities.
A biomarker is a defined characteristic that's
measured that is an indicator of a biological or
pathological process or response to an
exposure or an intervention.
And the types of biomarkers that are applicable for these
opportunities can be diagnostic, prognostic,
predictive, monitoring, or
pharmacodynamic.
The type of biomarkers can also be molecular,
cellular, or imaging,
but in this case,
in vitro imaging modalities is what is meant by imaging,
not clinical radiology. So clinical radiology is not
applicable for this type of funding opportunity.
The first phase, or the phase of analytical validity,
refers to how reliable the measurement is for
assessing the analyte, and that's defined by certain
performance characteristics, including accuracy,
precision, sensitivity, and specificity.
And the second phase, the phase of analytical validity, refers
to how reproducible the association is between the measurement
and the clinical outcome of interest.
The
two funding opportunities that I'll be talking about,
the mechanism is cooperative agreements,
and they're meant to bridge the gap between a
biomarker discovery that is usually supported perhaps
via an R01 mechanism, and
the end of the pipeline that refers to clinical
utility qualification, FDA approval of a
biomarker. So in between those two, we have analytical
validation and clinical validation, and that's what these funding
opportunities are meant to
support.These cooperative agreements are
for investigator-initiated research that would advance these
biomarker assays.
And the reason why they are cooperative agreements is
because that feature will enable the NCI staff with
expertise to assist the investigators to meet requirements for
analytical and clinical validation.
As I mentioned, the UH2/UH3 mechanism is a
phased award. It has an initial UH2 phase of
analytical validation for which funding is up to
$275,000 for up to two
years. And the prerequisite for application is to have an
assay that works within human specimens that are appropriate
for the clinical context of use. That is to say,
if the clinical context will be a liquid biopsy, then
the assay has to already work on
blood. It cannot be an assay that, let's say,
was developed using tissue and has never been tested in
blood.
The
transition from the analytical validation phase to the clinical
phase will require the
achievement of milestones. These milestones that are
proposed by the PI during the application,
refer to the performance criteria for analytical
validity that include accuracy, precision,
sensitivity as mentioned.
And there will be an administrative review of
which the program officer will lead,
that will
allow the investigator to move from this
analytical validation phase to the next
phase or UH3 for clinical
validation.
The UH3 phase of the grants will have a funding
of up to $250,000
annually for up to three years. And the outcome of this phase
will be to have a biomarker assay
that is reproducibly associated with a clinical
endpoint in patient samples.
When an assay is already analytically validated, the PI
can apply to what we call the standalone UH3
mechanism. It supports the clinical validation of
the analytically validated assays in similar way as the
second phase of the phased awards.
The prerequisite here is to have this existing assay,
and it has to be shown in the application that the
relevant performance criteria are being met.
And on top of that, there have to be plans and
documentation of availability and pre-approvals for
access of clinical trial or study specimens that
are being used in the clinical validation.
Similarly, as before, the outcome is to have a
biomarker that is associated with a clinical endpoint and
ready for use in trials or other studies.
These are some biomarkers and assays that are currently
supported by the program. We support a
variety of technology of platforms that are listed on the
slide: sequencing, PCR, methylation,
multiplex immunofluorescence, mass spec, et cetera.
They go together with a variety of biospecimens,
of which mostly we have FFP tissues, but also
increasingly blood.
We're supporting increasing number
of liquid biopsy tests
and a variety of analytes,
of which again, RNA is the most common, but
ctDNA is increasingly important.
A couple of examples of some success stories.
These are
three tests that were developed in part
with support from the UH2/UH3 program.
The first one,
EasoGuard and EasoCheck,
to identify Barrett's esophagus, which is a
precursor of esophageal
adenocarcinoma
through
methylation sites in cyclin A1 and
vimentin. And this assay has now received
FDA approval.
OncoUrea multiplex assay interrogating a
10-protein signature in urine associated with
bladder cancer, has now received
breakthrough device designation by FDA, and
MCL35 gene expression assay based
on expression of 17 proliferation genes that leads to
risk stratification of patients with mantle cell
lymphoma.
An important feature of this last one is that it's used most
commonly in FFP biopsy tissues. You can
read more at the
PubMed
links indicated on the slide. And I wanted to
point out that although ideally some of
these assays will follow a route to FDA approval, the
goal of the program is not regulatory approval,
but assay readiness for clinical use.
So many of the assays that are supported continue to be used
as laboratory developed tests.
A few words about what will be considered
non-responsive to this call. Those are projects that
support clinical trials because this is intended to bring assays to the
point where they can be integrated into future clinical trials
or studies,
applications that propose early stage development of
technologiesFor that purpose,
the type of opportunities that were mentioned earlier
by Annie's talk would be more appropriate
for this
type of early-stage development.
Applications with assays where the performance
has not been analytically validated in specimens similar to
those intended for clinical use, as the example I mentioned
earlier, or projects focused on technology development
for assays or biomarker discovery
that are covered
by IMAT, as mentioned earlier by Lokesh, or the
EDRN, Early Detection Research Network at the NCI.
Of course, if you have any questions about suitability
of an application, you can send us an
inquiry at the
dedicated email address that you can see on the slide,
and send some details
about your idea and your specific aims and the status of your
assay.
And that's all from me.
You can
find my address on the slide and a
summary of the funding opportunities that we talked
about, both the phased and standalone application that are
active currently, with due dates in July
and October, and the forecasted one that
will support both the phased and standalone
UH3 applications.
The QR code will take you to the Cancer Diagnosis
Program page, where you can learn more about
how we support development of diagnostics.
You can also send inquiries to the CDP
dedicated email address. And
make sure on your way out, you pick up a flyer that
lists all of the opportunities that were discussed, and they are
right outside the door on a chair. And thank you
very much. I guess we'll take questions now.
All right, folks, any question?
We have our panel here. Please go ahead.
That was very useful.
Specifically for the UH2, UH3,
if you were looking at a circulating biomarker,
specifically a profile of
circulating immune markers,
and the endpoint was seeing the same pattern of
change in the solid tumor,
is that
an appropriate clinical validation, or would you need to have
survival or some other
larger endpoint?
Thank you for that question. I think we would have to see the
specifics of the proposal because the
aim is to prepare an assay that can be used
within a clinical trial or clinical study-
Mm-hmm
... and has a clear outcome
associated-
Response to treatment-
Associated
... in this case.
Right. So if it is treatment response,
I
would have to see the details, but it wouldn't
matter as much that you go from blood to tissue, as
long as your outcome of interest has a clear
context of use.
Okay.
Does that help?
It helps.
Feel free to email with-
Okay
... specific questions.
The goal would be to have a blood test that would make it
unnecessary to take the biopsy because you are confident
enough that the blood test represents what's going on in the tumor.
Right. So I guess I
understood it a little bit reversed the way you explained it.
But if you are coming from tissue where the discovery happened,
and then you would want to apply that to a liquid
biopsy test-
Mm
... the way to come into this
funding opportunity would be to have a
test
that you can readily apply to blood where you
can proceed with the analytical validation.
Okay.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Yes, it does.
Okay.
Thank you.
And I guess you have to show some correlation, right?
Oh, yeah.
I guess. Yeah. So
I think that probably would be your preliminary data.
Okay. Well, thank you.
I think.
Yeah, I have a question regarding a
tissue bank.
So
do you have any requirement for
a funding source? Let's say I try to apply
for a specific type of tissue
or a plasma sample, for example.
Mm-hmm.
Do you require
NCI support or some funding source,
or just say I try to use your
cross-match bank resources
support later, use your resources to try to-
Yes
... to support a grant application?
I get this question, yes.
You're writing an application. Let me understand this.
You are writing a grant application where you have a component of
tissue requirements.
Yeah.
Okay. So what you can do is
you can get tissues in a number of ways, but if you want to
count on NCI's resources,
those tissues, one of them is available for
any purposes that you want to use. That is
CHTNTissue Network,
that you can
prescribe or you can say that this is what I need,
and they will provide the tissue to you with a
given price.
And for your application part of it, if you
applied already for the tissue, you could take that piece of paper,
attach to your grant application that, I have resources.
What you're saying is, "I have resources.
I have already applied for tissue, and I'm going to get it."
So that's the path to follow. But if you
need
NCTN or National Clinical Trials Network banks'
tissues, then it takes a little more time, and it's a
little more organized approach to why you want that
tissue. That tissue is not available
for exploratory studies. When your study is already
done, your validation is pretty much complete, but you
want to do clinical validation, that's where those
tissues are going to be very helpful.
Got that?
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Sure.
Because you talk about a lot of different cancer type,
because you need a healthy control population sometimes-
Sure
... especially blood. Do you have any information?
You can also ask them that I want the controlled tissues.
Okay. Thank you.
That's for through CHTN.
Okay. I've not looked at your resources yet.
I probably go back to look online.
Sure.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you very much for a great seminar, and I have a quick question
for Biobank.
Are there any tissue or organoid bank with
the genotyped information, such as
mutation pattern or expression profile,
attached to that tissue or organoid?
Good question. The thing is,
you are talking about the NCTN clinical
trials
by specimen bank tissues.
That's where you get those information, if at all.
Yes. If there are any type of-
Because it is coming from the clinical trials, so most of the work
they wanted to do with the tissue, that has been done.
That's why it is available to you. So that's the source you would
apply for your purposes.
It is not for CHTN, where you ask for
tissues, they will give you the tissue, but they don't have any background
information except pathology report.
And if-
Got that?
Yes. Thank you very much.
Sure.
And I have a last question. So if we would like to
apply for those tissue bank,
what type of criteria do you use to pass or
not pass for distribution?
Yes. The thing is,
you apply through
Navigator. It's a platform. Anybody can do that.
So you have to sign up and get
your own
login
information, apply to them, but you have
to tell them why you need these precious tissues.
Justify it. Not a huge essay for it,
but strong justification that I have done this
work.
Now I'm stuck. I need clinical samples to
validate my assay or validate my hypothesis.
That will get some traction for you.
I see. Thank you so much.
So a couple of more things just to add
that I think are going to be useful for you,
that you look into the HCMI,
so the Human Cancer Models Initiative.
So that's a database and repository that
has organoids and has been
characterized genomically. And if you look it up,
HCMI is not related to the Cancer Diagnosis Program.
It's another different part of NCI.
But I think HCMI may be closer to what you're
asking about.
What does HCMI stand for?
HCMI, Human Cancer Models Initiative.
And then for the purpose of the pass or fail,
when you do communicate with CHTN,
for instance, and you ask them to
prospectively acquire tissue for you, you can
communicate the needs that you have for whatever the
tissue resource should reflect.
And then Cancer Research Biobank, I'll let you-
Yeah, no. You asked about the sequencing, right, for some of the tissues.
And if you're looking for targeted sequencing,
there's available sequencing data from,
I would say, around one third of patients
available. The collection I showed you, so I think if you're looking
for
Oncomine Light data for around
300 odd patients, then to think that would be available through
dbGaP.
Okay. I have one other question.
You talk about
some grant opportunity from R1 research
related to U grant, UH2 grant.
So seems like for biomarker study,
so for me, I think it's public can apply for all
this.
Which type of biomarker is good for
R1 grant, which is good for U1 grant?
This seems like
it's no difference
There is no such thing as R01 or U01-
Yeah
... for a good biomarker.
Your application would be seen as where
it goes based on what you write there.
So if you have a biomarker in your mind,
use it
and let it fly
to the place it wants to be, because based on what you wrote
overall-
Yeah
... your application goes into that channel.
Okay? Unless you pick up your own...
For example, Anna has a number of
initiatives for biomarker development.
That's a focused approach, and Anna could speak about that.
Okay. So because for my case, we have one publication
demonstrate the usefulness of specific
blood-based biomarkers.
So, the grant for future grant application,
do I need to still go to the R01 grant or
go to U01 grant?
No.
Yeah.
R01 is not going to entertain that kind of thing.
Okay.
This is your U-
U grant.
So it depends, right, which step you are
on that biomarker development pipeline.
Yeah.
The U grant, the UH2, UH3, is very
focused on
the two pieces that you need to bring a biomarker to clinic.
So you already have to
have
zeroed in on what your biomarker is and how
to measure it.
Usually, when you're at the point of discovery, you
may have done
sequencing and validated in some external
cohort that there is an association.
Mm-hmm.
That's generally not enough to move a biomarker
through analytical validation towards clinical use, because
you don't necessarily have an assay.
Yep.
And you don't have any parameters.
So you need to develop it a little bit further,
which you might be able to do with an R01, and then you come
in to this very focused sort of
transitional phase towards
the clinical use.
Yeah, that's interesting.
Yeah.
So I guess it's you have to have the end in mind to
decide where you're going to be submitting that
application.
Okay.
And then you have to tailor it to the specific
needs of the application, right?
I think it should be
the R01 grant, because we just have one publication.
Mm-hmm.
We want more cohort to validate
the discovery, then we move to maybe UH2 grant.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Sandra, any question?
Yeah. I just have one question.
I work on lung cancer, and sometimes
we are interested in some... I have some lung tissues with me,
but sometimes we are interested in particularly lung
cancer from non-smokers, which is not available very easily,
and sometimes we want to get lung cancer from smokers.
So
where can we get lung tissues from smokers or non-smokers?
Yes.
Do you guys want to take it, or I will take it?
Yeah. Why don't you go? I'll add to it then.
Yeah. So
it seems like
you are looking at CHTN,
Tissue Network, where whatever you want,
they will try to get it to you.
From the Tissue Network?
For the Tissue Network, CHTN network.
HTN, right?
Yeah. C-H-T-N.
C-H-T-N. Okay.
C as in Charlie.
Yeah.
H-T-N.
HTN. T-H-T-N. Okay.
So if you go there,
you will be able to
tell them, "Okay, this is what I need, lung
cancer tissue." They will try to get it for you.
I see.
But other banks that we have, other banks means the
NCCN banks,
you can also apply there,
but they will ask you whether you have an assay
at the advanced level or anything in advanced level that you want to
validate. That's where these tissues come in, because these are very
precious. The alternative is, do you have
any pathologist, or you work with any pathologist in your
university or school?
Yes, we have some pathologists in our school.
That is the quick and easy way of getting it.
I have some extra lung tissue if you want.
Oh, good.
I'm in the Bronx, at Montefiore Einstein.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have a biobank.
Oh, very good. Then he said that.
There you go.
Yeah.
But my question is, can I get some CHTN, whatever funding to support our
biobanking efforts? Because we're going to-
Well, that's a different story. You're looking for funding.
Yeah. I
use this tissue too. I would have participated in Moonshot, but I give a tissue
institutionally.
The funding is-
Right
... a different story that we have to have RFA of
NOFO available
just for that particular type of
activities.
Yeah, but I think CHTN, you can always apply when it opens up,
right? I think there's... It's-
I think it's been opened now.
No, I think it's got renewed until, what, '28, I guess.
So then-
Yeah.
It's been open since-
So, but he may not-
Yeah
... be the right person. It has six different,
very structured places in the country.
Those institutions get it. If you could
create a liaison with one of them,
then you could get in that way.
Other than that, to crack in as a new investigator to
have a CHT unit-
Yeah
... would be highly competitive.
So to answer your question about non-small cell, I think the
Moonshot has some samples, I know, but depends.
Moonshot?
Yeah, the Cancer Moonshot Biobank, which would be probably available.
Oh, Cancer Moonshot Biobank. I can ask them.
Yeah. But depends, are you looking at longitudinal?
Are you looking at just probably one time point?
That will depend upon what kind of research you're
doing, right?
But they would be available. I think we have around close
to 276 patients.
That's not bad.
But then they have-
So we are basically comparing various biomarkers between
smokers and non-smokers.
Non-smokers, yeah. You will have-
So we are going very longitudinal.
Mm-hmm.
Just doing a black and white comparison.
Yeah, you will have that data.
Because we can get a lot of smokers, but the non-smokers
are the problem.
Are the problems, yeah. So we have that data, I guess, that's captured
as a part of the clinical data.
So it's Moonshot?
Yeah. We are working on the catalog.
So I think at probably end of the year you may have a
catalog ready.
So it's Cancer Moonshot Network. Tissue Network?
Cancer Moonshot Biobank. So if you-
Biobank.
Yeah.
So Cancer Moonshot Biobank.
Right.
Okay. I can
search it out on Google and then try to contact them.
Right. But it's not available yet, but I guess samples would be available
maybe end of the year as a part of the catalog.
And I think to Ani's point, right, if you want to look at specimens
now, you can go to the SRL, Specimen
Resource Locator. That's kind of a catalog that where
you can look at what all tissues are available and who has access to
it, where that's available.
Specimen Resource Locator is
with the NIH, yeah?
Yeah.
NCI supported. Specimen Resource Locator.
I believe all of these acronyms are represented in that
flyer that I mentioned.
Yeah, I got the flyer.
Okay.
I have that.
SRL might help, because you have access to at least over
40 or 50 different resources that they have
tissues available for you.
But NCI does not involve into
your transaction.
It is supported by NCI
for different
tissue resources.
So we can just buy them, right?
You can apply, you talk to them.
Yeah, just apply and buy them.
Yeah.
The charges are there, we just buy them.
If I were you, I'll talk to them first.
If I were you, I will talk to them so that the person could
guide you to the right place.
Thank you so much. Appreciate it very much.
Welcome.
I came late. I probably missed some information.
So I come from Mayo Clinic,
we have ovarian cancer SPOR, and
I'm kind of relatively new to Mayo, but I realized we
have almost more than 2,000 plasma
samples with an average of 16 years
follow-up data.
And we also have more than 600 PDX
developed. So I was wondering,
and
that we have the SPOR and some of the efforts were supported by
SPOR now, but because this kind of enriched
resource, is there any opportunity for us
to
seek funds from this program, this kind of program?
Well,
you are with Mayo?
Yes.
They have SPOR already.
Yeah.
That is supporting the comprehensive
cancer center.
Yes.
Yes. So you are getting funded there.
Now if you want to get additional funding-
Uh-huh
... it would be a different application.
And of course, one can apply,
but what would be the logic to apply for that?
They will ask you whether you have a SPOR.
You already have a SPOR.
Well, some are PDX, we have animal model cores,
so that was supported. And these
plasma samples, basically it's
collected way more longer than the SPOR has
been funded.
Mm.
So we have still going on, and we also use it for
some biomarker studies. One of my study was recently found, like some
very useful
information and
just wondering, where these kind of more
than 2,000 samples with a very long time follow-up is
kind of-
So what you can do-
And well characterized the samples as well.
Some of the patients also have the patient
sequencing data and...
What you can do is,
you are looking at a U24 mechanism.
Can you use the microphone? I cannot hear very well. I'm sorry.
Yeah. What you can do is you could use a U24
mechanism, that's the infrastructure grant.
Could you repeat that? What mechanism? U?
U24.
24.
It's a infrastructure development grant.
Okay.
You could apply and see what happens.
But make sure you have a proper, solid
justification for it.
Uh-huh. Not apply from a
very currently funded-
No, make sure that-
... source. Right
... your needs are-
Yeah
... pretty clear-
Uh-huh
... on the application process.
So my other question-
If what you're looking for also is to make those
thousand samples available for community use, they
could be linked to the SRL, the Specimen Resource Locator.
Uh-huh.
So you would incorporate your resource into that
large database so that people would know how to find you.
Mm-hmm.
And then they might connect with you and acquire,
as Ani mentioned,
just negotiate with you to acquire whatever they need out of
your specific database. If what you're asking about is how to make
those available-
I think they're looking for funding
... for the SRL.
He wants funding.
Yeah.
This has been collected. There are still efforts-
Yeah
... it's collecting.
Right.
But we don't need to go endless. It's already more than-
Yeah
... 2,000, almost maybe close to 3,000 now.
But
our problem is we are collecting butIf we
want to fully analyze this, and we need to really
advance to explore that, and even enter code into a much
smaller virus takes a lot of resources.
Like how are we going to use it? And
link the information together.
What is happening here is you are
jumbling up things.
You have to separate out
whether you want a
infrastructure development
grant or you want exploratory grant.
Uh-huh.
That has to be clear in your mind,
so you pick and choose the
funding mechanism that you want.
What you are saying that you want to do research on it.
Infrastructure will be more like a super I think. Yeah.
Storage facility.
Yeah.
That you will be able to share with others. That's the intent.
Yeah. Uh-huh.
But if you want to do further research on it, that component
is not going to be covered by U24.
Okay.
You need another mechanism to
come in to help you with that.
Okay.
Yeah. Thank you.
It is quite possible that your SPOR
program officer might be able to
guide you-
Uh-huh. Yeah
... on what other type of funding might be available.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Anything else, folks?
Any other questions?
If not, we're going to probably wrap up
at this point. Thank you for listening.
Thank you.
I hope it was helpful to you,
and I thank my colleagues for their effort to
present here
and to give you the best we have. Have a wonderful day.
All right. Thank you.